two bottles of vodka is this gonna be
the weekend we finally meet six-drink
amy
six-drink amy what does that mean it's
the pinnacle of the Santiago drunkenness
scale one drink
Amy's a little Spacey wait what
two drinks loud Amy you want to get a
cab three drinks
Amy dance pants four-drink amy is a bit
of a pervert hey check it out
when five drug Amy is weirdly confident
let's do this little man but I've never
seen
six-drink amy maybe she's the one I
could actually be friends with aka my
sasquatch Mina you ready to party or why
don't mind if I uh uh
wow you're two shots behind linetti i
boiled Rosa and Amy you're up come on
get on it and under it bangerang am
saying this hmm you don't want to be
around Holt in your current state say
hello to the most confident woman alive
yeah drink number five you are a true
friend and a hot little piece good-bye
four-drink amy sloppy sicko what the
hell guys can't just let Scully go run
tree wants guys if we're gonna pull this
off we need to focus you want to play
yeah I want to play it's quarters what
am i a monster Terry tag me in your on
Holt party duty
it seems to me all-wheel Drive is
four-wheel drive
[Music]
I know they say it's not good to have a
TV in the bedroom which is why I don't
hey I told you guys this weekend wait
Terry aren't you supposed to be upstairs
not now it's nap time
what okay maybe and Hitchcock are still
upstairs I think we're still good oh no
six-drink amy isn't Flint she's just sad
we already got you idiot look who's here
how was your night of old school
drinking hmm
pretty hungover turn off your mouth
siren here the text I got from you last
night best night ever
why Scotch burned so good was his name
in Serpico who's the friend of yours
with the ping-pong and lastly a picture
of you on the subway platform eating
Chinese chicken salad with no shirt on
well last night was awesome we had an
epic night of bonding that I will never
forget do it I believe in you
throw it I believe in you
there you are you okay sir No
until this morning some small part of me
still believed I would be captain of the
nine-nine again what a fool I was
I should never have returned it's like
visiting your childhood home and seeing
it's been replaced by a denim pants
store whoa whoa slow down sir you didn't
even stop and sniff the bouquet you
always sniff the bouquet maybe the old
hold did but the new Holt chugs
Beaujolais from a burgundy glass without
a care oh it's a soft turn glass look
the alcohol has rendered me a simpleton
maybe you should just call it a day
I can't I've been asked to deliver a
toast here after the funeral a message
of hope this is what I have so far
pain that's it one tweak maybe you
should lose the word pain and then
getting a cab and go home maybe I will
but first they're gonna have one drink
with me Sardar
for old times sake one drink and then we
go one drink Rosa you go to the office
have a couple believes and just relax
it's a believe me peach juice and
champagne peach juice and champagne one
more six come on just try it
it's what Nancy Meyers would drink fine
for Nancy Amy we've got a problem
what Rosa's drunk Rosa know how Bellinis
rule Nancy Meyers you've done it again
you saucy [ __ ] Rosa what happened sorry
I didn't know you could get drunk off
champers I mean it's half bubbles
don't worry hey me I got this I'm a
master at sobering up are you sure you
don't go to the Renaissance Fair every
weekend in your 20s without learning how
to handle your Mead
great thanks Ralphie hey Charles get
married today yes you are and I'm gonna
make sure you are sober when that
happens now I just need cayenne pepper
and some horse milk marriage is the best
hey how come you and Genevieve our mood
huh uh you know it's complicated
no it's not it's easy brew down here
we'll get married yeah right she doesn't
want that
oh that sounds no no everything's great
with us I mean if it was up to me we'd
get hitched but she had a really bad
divorce so oh sorry
does that upset you I'm good yeah I'm
good I'm so sad I love her so much I
want to marry her but so bad to Genovese
buds and Genovese but why can't they
stay babies forever Merlini
and that's why you shouldn't drink being
drunk sounds terrible hello Amy I didn't
see you there how did the wedding go
Terry what the hell man you said you're
gonna sober them up their fall
my girls are never gonna grow up and
lose their virginity I lost my vCard to
the woman that refilled Nana's oxygen
tanks her hands were so strong from
turning the nozzles this is a room of
nightmares
you're the nightmare you made me kill my
balloon baby look at me so drunk I'm a
liberating like a beatnik you paid the
bodega guy $200 for those anti shirt oh
that explains why I have a triple XL
Scarface hoodie on my couch worth it
it's pretty fun night no I'm pretty good
right yes it's like a Bonnie Raitt
concert in here yeah hey we're budgeted
the Taser challenge you guys won in
what's the Taser challenge it K's each
other then drink how do you win what are
you a lawyer you want in or not yeah
Terry what your lawyer it's tasers get
tased at a party man come on okay he's
gone
now I just gotta wait for k13 to give us
the all-clear yeah I wouldn't hold your
breath dumb robot partner rolled into
the stairwell so I should be best
friends this 10k 13 says we are G to G
Amy this justice lifted
[Applause]
[Applause]
look there's six shirt it looks Bert
because I was on fire hits the pillow
shirt it's all coming back to me okay so
if this is definitely where we set off
the fireworks but still no laptop how
did I catch on fire oh no I just
remember something
Terry feels bad hence the chest pain but
what was that loud crash I could get
might have been me see you now partner
you killed her
her oh my god it was a herd you're
replacing Amy not me hey ton wait the
robot has a camera maybe she saw who
took the laptop there's the laptop bag
you think you're so much better than me
right it's gonna fast forward
oh hey robot I got something really cool
to show you on the balcony I like it
fast forward did you guys see that you
put the bag down behind the plant let's
go this is there this is there oh no
sweetie oh hello I'm captain Raymond
holt and if I had the pleasure of
joining your board here are some of the
things I would do see it all worked out
with you're a wild party with absolutely
zero consequences Jake something's wrong
oh oh I I don't know how they got in
there or what it is I'll just uh next
slide well that's strange next slide
next next oh I see what's happening here
ah due to an issue with the internet
cloud you are seeing a series of
pictures that have nothing to do with me
or the 99th
you